dans le quartier des spectacles l'équipe
de juste pour rire met la dernière
touche aux préparatifs du festival qui
débute demain il y a de la fébrilité
dans l'air rendez vous amoureux
s'étaient longtemps qu'attendu et qui
sait plus trop comment ça se passe mais
il faut que tu aies itsm au nylon piton
rouge à lèvres du sa mission est simple
comme ça jusqu'au 24 juillet les
festivaliers pourront assister en plein
air à des animations déambulatoires ou à
l'une des soixante représentations de
spectacles extérieurs gratuits
c'est le retour du bonheur c'est le
retour de l'espoir c'est le retour d'une
équipe complètement fou où on a réussi à
réinventer le festival en gros pourquoi
tu es célibataire
dès cette année encore le festival fait
la part belle aux nouveaux visages
les humoristes connus on les connaît
très très bien le mode et la nouvelle
relève et lopy poche et ont beaucoup de
talent et il ya aussi des humoristes la
diversité pichon à montréal qui sont
québec mais qui avait jamais la porte
d'entrée pour mirage parmi eux taille
une jeune sensation des réseaux sociaux
qui transportera son humour et son
occupation houde d'instagram à la scène
de l'olympia ya beaucoup de diversité on
retrouve vraiment de tout dans le live
tu vois il ya des québécois des haïtiens
des arabes des latinos puis c'est ça qui
fait en sorte que le monde a dans le
lait
en parallèle du festival juste pour rire
se déroule le zoofest au monument
national
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
de nouveaux talents et pour les
humoristes de la relève de monter sur
scène dans de bonnes conditions
s'ils n'aiment kara se produira pour la
quatrième fois c'est la possibilité
d'avoir des salles professionnels du
matériel professionnel qui jouer dans
des conditions humaines
le festival juste pour rire est le
premier grand événement culturel à se
tenir sur la place des festivals depuis
le début de la pandémie de quoi ramener
des gens dans le centre-ville et des
sourires sur les visages des commerçants
avec l'espoir que les meilleurs jours
sont à venir ici mais bien ex andré
chartier radio canada morin